one of the interesting things going on
in the world right now is that there's
lots of billionaires people have built
some massive businesses solved a lot of
customers problems they're starting to
get a lot more public about some of
their thoughts and one of those topics
ends up being inflation obviously
inflation's sitting about 8.3 percent
near a 40-year high and the average
american is suffering in this
environment and so as these billionaires
as these entrepreneurs and problem
solvers start to talk more publicly
about it there's a lot of folks who
don't like hearing that capitalism may
actually be a great solution and
government intervention may not be the
dream that so many people tried to sell
to the public now yesterday during the
all-in summit we saw elon musk join the
four hosts of that podcast and they
asked him exactly about inflation jeff
bezos tweeting at president biden and
here is what elon musk had to say
elon did you see uh jeff's
uh bezos's tweet back and forth with
biden
where biden i think was talking about
inflation inflation but then he
correlated that to taxing corporations
and bezos said this is misinformation
and disinformation et cetera et cetera
what do you what do you think about that
whole exchange then back and forth
i mean the obvious reason for inflation
is that the government printed a zillion
amount more money than it had
obviously um so it's like the government
can't just issue checks far in excess of
revenue without there being inflation um
you know velocity money held constant
and if if there are more dollars created
then the increase in the goods and
services output of the economy then you
have inflation if the government could
just issue
a
massive amount of money and have it and
deficits didn't matter then why don't we
just make the deficit a hundred times
bigger
okay the asterisk can't because it will
basically turn the dollar into something
that is worthless and various countries
have have tried this experiment multiple
times it's not like oh i wonder what
happens if this if this is done yeah
have you seen venezuela the true economy
is the output of goods and services it's
not money
now part of the reason why i love elon
musk is because he's got a great way of
articulating some ideas including hey if
the deficit doesn't matter just increase
it by 100x shouldn't be a big deal right
well obviously no one's advocating for
that and the reason is because the
deficit does matter and so naturally
regardless of what the talking points
coming out of the white house or in the
mainstream media are most people
understand that you can't print money
and not get inflation they printed
trillions and trillions of dollars they
stuffed it in every exotic corner of the
financial system and it led to 8.3
official inflation the real inflation
rate is probably in the mid teens and
naturally what we're seeing is the
people who run businesses the people who
deal with supply chains the people who
actually have to go and get materials
for their business they see the
inflation they understand what's
happening and now they're armed with
twitter accounts and they're willing to
publicize their opinions this is a
nightmare for politicians but naturally
i'm going to trust the entrepreneurs who
have solved problems for billions of
customers because ultimately they
probably know a little bit more about
the real world than the politicians the
bureaucrats and those individuals who
are appointed in academic circles hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time